do
hey folks welcome to the unity 2020
campfire
i am here with dan crenshaw former navy
seal
current representative of texas second
congressional district welcome dan
hey thanks for having me brett it's good
to see you again good to see you
um i'm gonna give a very brief
introduction since i know you're pressed
for time
uh we use campfire as a mechanism for
discussing the predicament that the
nation
finds itself in the unity
2020 coalition are patriots who are
interested
in figuring out how to escape our highly
polarized partisan dynamic
to save the republic so you are a
perfect guest for such
a conversation i should say that the
hope for this conversation was that it
would include
tulsi gabbard who is unfortunately
now off on her military assignment and
couldn't join us perhaps when she
returns we'll be able to have that
conversation
but in the meantime i'm very pleased to
welcome you
to the unity 2020 campfire
thanks for having me let's talk about uh
the situation
first i should alert you that we at
unity 2020 have just
completed soliciting nominations for our
ticket
and uh last i checked you were
very popular nominated many many times
near the top of our list
so in any case you are here amongst
people
who uh see you in a very favorable light
in fact maybe before we get to the
discussion we have a graphic
this is not absolutely current data but
zach could you put up that graphic
so here uh oh apparently you can't see
it
um we asked the question i think this is
on august
5th we asked how do you feel about dan
crenshaw
and the answer that
was submitted was always felt his
statements were honest even if i
disagree
and then democrats in our group
agreed with that statement at a rate of
68 republicans slightly better at 70
and people who have not previously been
engaged in politics agree with that
statement at 80 percent
so there's something about you dan that
resonates with a lot of people
people see you as uh as a patriot and i
must say i i see you in the same way
oh well thank you i have no plans to run
for
the higher office but i do appreciate
i do appreciate it either way well we uh
we have no
plans to run you for higher office
unless uh our nomination process goes
that way and we have groundswell enough
to uh draft you uh as a matter of simple
patriotism and
dedication to the nation but let's um
let's talk about what our national
predicament might be um the people who
have joined our movement
are quite concerned about what they're
seeing and although they are of course
not of one
mind i think a great many of us believe
that we are watching something
historic take place and that many of the
things that have felt secure
to americans are suddenly looking
like they may be a bit more rickety than
we thought
do you see that picture oh yeah i mean i
think we i think everybody feels that
whether you're on the far right or the
far left or in the middle moderate
there's there's certainly a sense
of polarization and it's it's and i
think people feel a bit helpless with it
because it's
nobody has a clear sense of how to drive
ourselves out of that polarization
um the the immediate reaction if you're
on the left is to say well the right
started and if you're on the right the
immediate reaction is that the left
started it they need to change these
things and
and and then we will be able to move
forward
um the the moderates will say well
that's both sides
and you know and i'm of course i'm on
the right and i
i do believe the statement that i think
you know it's probably more the fault of
the other and i can
i'm happy to be challenged on these
things um
but this that's that's the helplessness
that i think americans feel and
they feel like they want a way out of it
yeah i would agree with that
um although you know you and i
uh had a couple conversations on your
podcast your podcast which is
um called we hold these truths
which is excellent and although i would
consider myself on the far left and you
consider yourself
on the right we found a tremendous
amount over which
we disagree we agreed and very little
over which we disagreed
and i must say that this has been a uh a
fairly frequent theme in my
conversations of late
that essentially good people seem to
agree on a lot
what's interesting about that is how
people label themselves um
you know yeah you've said that a few
times that you're like a radical
leftist and then but i can't find any
sort of radical left
um things that you believe maybe you'll
surprise me um
but this gets to a different um problem
so labels are useful um
especially for political science and for
just i think general
uh you know i i think study and
in general politics you have to to a
certain extent
um but you know people label themselves
uh voluntarily too
and and so this is this is an
interesting thing that i've had to
that i've had to be more self-conscious
of and i crossed the line probably a lot
but let me just tell you a story so
you know my district is it's it's
somewhat diverse it's an urban suburban
district we've got a lot of really like
cool hot spots
um in my district i like to do events
at popular bars i just find that fun it
brings a younger crowd i
i think it's just fun and you get to
kind of just have a beer with people
it's one of my favorite ways to campaign
um and and do my job which is
effectively
representing people and communicating
with people and um
haven't been able to do it a lot lately
which has been very frustrating but
there's a place i like to go to often
and so they know who i am that's kind of
the point i'm making i do a lot of
events there they know who i am
and um and they don't seem to dislike me
all right and i remember just that being
there
you know just getting some food one day
and grabbing a beer
and um the bartender was there again
this
this woman who knows me like there's
there's
i'm not a stranger to them i know
exactly who i am and uh
you know she's young she's covered in
tattoos um
i come from the military we've got a lot
of tattoos in the military i have
tattoos
and i'm like hey those are pretty cool
tattoos and she says um
yeah you know i come from you know in my
neighborhood you know just north of
houston it's more conservative but i'm
more progressive and so
i like tattoos and i found that so
interesting that she would label herself
as a progressive
um because of the tattoos see i i would
never do that
so what this what this revealed to me
was that when i'm criticizing
progressives and progressivism in
general
she might think i'm criticizing her when
in reality
we might agree on a whole number of
things and obviously from these
interactions
she has no ill will towards me you know
and she knows my political beliefs and
she must
so people self-label and
and we just have to be careful with that
and you know i i try to distinguish
who i'm talking about more carefully
again i don't think i always do a great
job of this
but i try to distinguish between a
liberal and a leftist and a progressive
and a far leftist a radical leftist
whatever these things
might mean and i try to explain what i
mean by these terms so that people so
that we don't alienate people and that's
probably a good
start you know part of the way of
getting out of the polarization is to
stop attacking the worst ideas from the
other side
um attack ideas directly
also don't don't don't play tennis with
each other in different courts
don't talk past each other because the
war of ideas is a healthy thing and i
and i engage in that war pretty
pretty heavy-handedly frankly um but
but you know i have to catch myself
sometimes and stop attacking
the worst ideas from the other side and
focusing on
on the labels or at least describing
what i mean by the labels
yeah well i think um the more i
see the older i get the more i realize
that patriotism has
failed and that part of the problem that
we run into is that many of the people
who are involved in these discussions
actually
for example root for the failure
of governance when it is in the hands of
those they regard as the opposition
which is deeply unpatriotic the fact is
at the point the other candidate is
elected you should be rooting for them
to succeed because
their success is our success and to root
for them to fail
and worse to engage in sabotage
is um well it's anti-american
and so oh go ahead yeah
i agree with that there's polling
there's very detailed polling on this on
this particular question about how you
feel about your country
and um who does it
i think it was pew i think it's pew
research that's been doing it for a long
time and so you can
so you can see how democrats and
republicans
um describe their patriotism because
they're asked
do you feel i think the question is
about patriotism do you feel very
patriotic about your country somewhat
patriotic et cetera
um for republicans it remains somewhat
constant
democrats it varies wildly depending on
who's president
there's those very clear swings
you know michelle obama said this was
the first time i'm proud of my country
she said that in 2008 when we elected
barack obama
and and to your point we can't say those
things we can't say our
it's there's no benefit to it you know
like this this notion that the only way
we can be proud of our country is if we
radically transform it the only way we
can love our country is if we radically
transform it
that's not the right attitude it's like
would you say that about your spouse
you know like that's i i really would
love her she would just radically change
herself
you know i have heard people say that
about their spouses but no i wouldn't
i wouldn't say that right but not but
not a healthy relationship
no so we should we should desire this
sort of healthy relationship with
with with the ideals of our country and
maybe that's what patriotism is
you know it doesn't mean you don't
desire uh progress doesn't mean you
don't desire
improvements but but we've gotten to the
point where we're trying to undermine
the very foundations of the country
basically throw it all out
you know kind of a french revolutionary
style and
that's that's to me is deeply dangerous
yeah well you say
um i mean let me put it a different way
i think
the core of patriotism is a willingness
to sacrifice
for your country so i find myself
very patriotic i don't have any doubts
about it i don't wonder about it
it doesn't mean that i'm not frustrated
with my country that i don't feel like
we could do better and sometimes we do
things that i find
um maddening and needless but it doesn't
dampen my willingness to sacrifice for
it because
it is um an immensely powerful
experiment
in human betterment it really is
the first credible departure from a
system in which we just
battle each other based on what
population we come from and one of the
things that
terrifies me about this movement is that
i see
the far left at the moment selling a
race first view of the world which is
going to drive
uh the right the mainstream right into a
race first view of the world that it
doesn't currently hold
and for us to abandon the american
experiment in favor of
um lineage against lineage
violence and power games seems to me
such a tragic
waste yeah well it's critical race
theory i mean
critical race theory it seems to me just
to be sort of a modern
academic exploration of what human
history has always been
which is viewing things through through
a
a racial lens or a tribal lens or a
group lens
group on group you know identity
politics which as you noted which
is kind of prior to western
enlightenment that
human civilization for a very long time
was just the warring of factions
and power struggles uh whether it's
again based on land but usually based on
some kind of
tribal loyalty whatever that looked like
and uh
the beauty of western civilization was
was overcoming that
you know and we and you know and we do
it and fits and starts
like we have a sinful history but we
but you know in the in the long
you know in the i would say in the in
the long perspective of history we did
it rather quickly
and forcefully we're never perfect um
and we but we can
no matter what though i can tell you
this we definitely can't change it we
can't change the history
history is unchangeable last time i
checked and
and this this need to dwell on it um
and and sort of ruin our our our current
history and our future
because of it uh it seems very backwards
to me and
and and i just think we're making we're
not we're not making progress with
something like critical race theory
viewing everything through the lens of
race or gender
or or whatever the immutable
characteristic is at the
given moment we're not making any
progress with that we're we're
regressing
and it's uh it's very divisive you know
and um
i don't i don't know that's it yeah i
worry about that on the right
i don't know if it'll end up that way on
the right it's um
you know as as the backlash i think the
backlash is is more
chaotic than that i don't i don't think
we
i i don't think the right really knows
how the left always accuses us by the
way i know listeners will say
oh of course the right does identity
politics i i don't see a lot of evidence
for that
um you know and then again and i could
go into that but
i think there's going to be backlash and
it's not going to be good
but it's it's unclear to me what it even
looks like
to be honest um well i must tell you
uh i don't see how it can
avoid that trap just the simple
experience that people have
of not knowing whether or not they're
going to be
viewed as racist for example just simply
because
we are being told that you can read that
on the on the surface of someone's skin
means that a a social situation that
might have been
ambiguous or even welcoming in the past
is going to be viewed with trepidation
uh in a future where where we're told
that race is everything
and i mean you said it i think quite
well
our history is far from perfect this was
a radical departure and a positive
one and the thing we're really fighting
over is whether or not
the right thing to do about our failures
is to finish the project and actually
live up to our aspirations to be a
race-blind
society or to regress as you say
to a former state where we don't aspire
to such things and what i find so
frustrating about the presentation i see
over on the far left at the moment
is that there is no awareness for what
has been accomplished
the obsessive focus on what we have not
yet accomplished
obsessive to the point that people even
invent failures that aren't real
but that obsessive focus leaves people
with the impression
that they are inherently worse off
so for example with respect to policing
right we see
failures of policing we don't
necessarily understand what they
are but we see lots of instances that
we're told are
evidence of brutal racist police
but the idea that eliminating the police
might be the solution to that
is preposterous right we don't see the
crimes that don't get committed
and many crimes don't get committed
because you can call the police and if
we eliminate them you won't be able to
and crime will predictably go up and
it's already going up in places
where this experiment is being run so
there's a
there's just a failure to appreciate
that which
you don't notice because we are
successful at it and to
focus only on those places where
plausibly we we
haven't succeeded yeah there's a severe
imbalance
and that that sort of lack of critical
thinking i think is purposeful
it's part of this movement um
part part of the philosophy the
post-modernist philosophy
is to make the argument that two plus
two equals five and if you argue with me
you're a racist
and it's it's confusing it's meant to be
confusing it's not meant to be logical
logical
logic is i mean and they'll say this
like i'm just repeating what they've
said logic means racism you know
and you know higher meritocracy means
racism this is and you're like what wait
a second
and and the thing is like your average
vote or your average like moderate
liberal person i don't think believes
these things
um but i what worries me
is in what i i think see objectively is
that that radical left
ideology is taking over
the in the broad sweeping left and
trampling over liberals and again we
should be protecting liberalism
uh i disagree with liberals i i think
they i think they
are a little bit too utopian i think
they want too much government to do
things that government can't possibly do
but but they're not they're not critical
race theorists
okay and they're not marxists um and we
and we have to distinguish between the
two it gets to my earlier point and i
have to be more conscious of that
sometimes but you know
i can't help my frustrations sometimes
um i i like the way um thomas soul
describes the uh getting getting to what
you said about
getting to a a color-blind society
and you know that that can mean i think
that's that
that means two things one is our
institutions and our legal system is
colorblind so that's one way of
describing it
and i think we have that um and then
there's and then the question is society
itself colorblind of course we don't
have that
and i don't think we ever will and so
this gets to the the question
where i bring up thomas sowell and his
and his work on the
the conflict of visions the
unconstrained vision versus the
constrained vision
these are two basic psychological states
in humanity and it's really interesting
how he applies them
and fundamentally how you would apply it
here would be you know the unconstrained
vision
means there's there's no restraint on
what institutions what government
institutions can do
to mold human nature so there's this
belief
that if we just get the right policies
in place we can actually make people a
certain way
now the constrained vision would say no
there's a constraint on what government
can actually accomplish
and and i and i see the policies and i
see this in joe biden's platform where
where you're going to make the fed have
another mandate
to fix racial inequality so you're going
to impose
non-colorblind color i guess visible
color
you know color visible policies in order
to
in order to mold the the non-color blind
human nature that
that we believe is inevitable and you
know the question is is that regressive
or is that progressive
i i think it's regressive oh you're
absolutely right it's regressive and
uh the democrats are engaged in it
cynically
i don't mean the democrats writ large
but the um
the democrats of the dnc are
toying with this not because it makes
the slightest bit of sense
but because it diverts attention away
from their own corruption and i mean
it's the most unpatriotic thing
that maybe i've seen in my lifetime
because what it does
is it takes the anger that people have
over a system that is not serving them
well
and it causes it to be redirected
towards other people on the basis of
skin color on the you know based on a
faulty explanation
that the only reason that you would have
an inequality
is because of oppression therefore
there's all this cryptic racism in the
heads of
white people that explains everybody any
failure anywhere in the system of
anybody to thrive which is just nonsense
and the real problem with that premise
is that it's unsolvable
and i think it's it's unsolvable by
design
okay because you can always keep arguing
for it
it'll never be solved if because because
they're by design they're not actually
solving the core issues which could be
education
you know poverty is is it has many
different faces there's different
reasons that somebody is in poverty
it's a complex conversation to fix that
but these these conversations will never
fix it and i think that's by design
because if you fix it well then what the
heck do you have to run on
you know how are you gonna how are you
going to get this vote the next time and
uh you know cynically the the easiest
way for politicians to get a vote is to
promise to do something for somebody to
provide some kind of service it's a very
easy campaign promise
um i you know to tocqueville said i
think the
the end of the republic comes when
politicians realize they can uh
they can promise people things with
their own money and
that's true that's always going to be an
issue with democracy you know it's
it's it nobody said it was perfect it's
just the most perfect thing we have this
sort of republic
that we have but um but it's unsolvable
and it traps people
that's the thing it traps people because
you're fighting against a very vague
narrative
that that is undefinable by
again by design and it's meant to trap
people and
it's that's depressing that's um it's
disempowering
and um and it's sad to watch it take
place
so i want to help you out as somebody
who's lived on
the left my whole life there are two
things going on on the left and one of
them
or maybe it's three there's the cynical
dnc
version of this where the symbolism
involved in
critical race theory and its relatives
is useful
as a an electoral distraction something
to motivate
voters to turn out for democrats then
you've got
cynical actors in the mainstream left
who are actually much as you say they've
built this
in and in fact if you listen to them
they will tell you
that the racism of whites for example
is incurable and the job of countering
it will never end they'll just say that
flat out so um i find the first time i
heard that i was just
stunned because so much is invested in
telling us that we have to counter this
and then in the next sentence they'll
tell you
it can't be countered and it's just a
very
bleak and self-serving portrayal
but the bulk of the people who are
following this have no idea what they're
signed up for
right they heard black lives matter and
they resonated and so they signed up and
they're not paying attention
to the details of the world view that is
being
advanced and wow are they going to be
surprised
that this is not about some world in
which things are more equal
this is about a future world in which
they're very unequal
in a very unfamiliar direction and it's
completely inconsistent
with any of the values that that bind us
together as americans
yeah i i don't even know how to respond
to that it's just i
agree with it um it's concerning
and uh it this is maybe this is what
we're trying to figure out is
how do you tell people that do you tell
them through a
kind of a philosophical historical
discussion you know it's hard for me to
reach everybody with a with a
philosophical discussion
and and kind of pointing these things
out and
and because moralizing is part of the
tactic um
these are moralizers i i think and
they talk at heartstrings the the
jonathan heights
um illustration of the writer and the
elephant
i know he's your friend so i know you
know what i'm talking about yeah but uh
you know the the
conscious and unconscious mind there's a
reason that the writers is just a
little guy up there with those you know
kind of control the elephant but it's an
elephant and that's the unconscious mind
and
that's mostly based on emotional
reasoning and so
the people pulling the strings here know
these things and they know that and they
know that people want to be good they
want to feel good
and it feels pretty good to be
anti-racist i mean who wouldn't want to
be anti-racist
and so it's it's by design these things
are by design
it's very clever um but the problem is
it's not sustainable and it always ends
in disaster because
it again how do you tell that to people
you've got to show them the history of
it
but i think then they'll counter it and
say oh no this time it's different
this time it's different it's always
different this time
and it's again it gets to this is why
people feel a little bit
helpless um and it's hard to find
a way out of it all we can do is keep
talking about her
well let's talk about how you uh
raise people's awareness because i do
you know it's a pity that
um the metaphor of uh
being awake is being so abused in this
case because i find most people
who are awoke are sleepwalking right
but in any case look you said some
things about
liberals first of all you said some
things about liberals versus leftists
versus progressives and frankly i have
been on the left my whole life and i
couldn't tell you
a reliable way to distinguish these
things i
somewhat resonate with all of those
terms though i resonate with
almost nothing that the people who who
are using those terms would say about
their own beliefs at the moment i
believe we need progress but i don't
believe we need progress of the type
that they're pushing
but in any case what you said which i
think is quite accurate
is that liberals tend to be too utopian
and they tend not to understand the
downside of the policies that they're
advocating
right so that they uh they're like
scientists who would add epicycles in
order to rescue a hypothesis rather than
recognize that it's just not stable so
let me tell you what i think the flip
side of this is the flip side of this
is that conservatives tend to be
too skeptical about the possibility
of a viable solution to a real problem
and they tend to be too optimistic about
our current state
so i think you're right liberals tend to
want to solve problems and they tend not
to understand that they may be causing
new and bigger problems
in so doing but conservatives tend to be
they will leave possible solutions on
the table
over fear of what might happen if they
attempted to solve it and disbelief over
the need for it
and so in some sense i this is why unity
2020
is structured the way it is the way to
reach people
is not to try to clarify these two
messages
it's to try to bring these two messages
together because
you know as i've grown older and i i
would hope
wiser i've come to understand that
it is the tension between these two sets
of instincts
in which the magic actually happens
right you need liberals to
imagine what might be possible that
would be better and you need
conservatives to keep them from uh
overdoing it and destroying functional
things in the pursuit of that which
cannot be
and i think there's been too much
carnage that comes from the pendulum
swinging back and forth
which i don't even think it does anymore
but it once did
that there's a you know your temperature
in your body isn't maintained by going
way too high and then way too low it's
tightly constrained to the right
temperature for all your enzymes to work
and it would be great if we could make
governance work that way too
but it is done with tension it's done
with those who see one side with clarity
partnering with those that see the other
side and reaching
some sort of rational plan yeah i
agree with that i like the way you frame
that i i frame it that way often myself
as far as this is the healthy balance of
liberal and conservative
um it's kind of a chaos versus order
conversation
i don't mean chaos in the pejorative
sense um
it's it's it's but it is kind of what
liberalism is
uh you know it's it's just like let's
just get it done
um and then conservatives are like no
just if
you do that then all of these other
things you know but but maybe if they're
maybe they're a little too like you said
they're too tightly wound to the
to that specific tradition or or
structure and so
you need a healthy balance um on a
practical level
and and maybe to answer your question
about how i define progressives and
leftists
you know just to just for everybody
knows what i'm talking about what i mean
these things progressivism
to me is woodrow wilson is wilsonian
progressivism
which is a a direct rebuke to the
constitutional order
a rebuke to the notion of checks and
balances because it gets in the way
of the progress so it's a highly
authoritarian highly centralized
highly planned economy from washington
that's how it started and that to me
that
it appears by all the policy measures
that they wish to take
but that's still what it is um but
progress always sounds good and so it's
a nice term
leftism i i define more and like the
again and obviously a lot of these
things overlap
but leftism i tend to define as kind of
the postmodernist
stuff that we're seeing that you really
criticize quite a bit
um that's what i see is leftism uh as
opposed to liberalism which i want
i want to still define as a good and
decent thing
which i have some issues with um but
it's also a necessary balance to
uh conservatism so as you noted and it's
because of that necessity
uh that necessary confrontation between
chaos and order that is a necessary
confrontation
um it's it's it's just true and so
now on a practical level how do we
resolve that with good natured liberals
the liberals are really good at pointing
out the the injustices within
kind of the hierarchies that are set in
society and they say
this isn't fair we don't like this okay
the market's not working in this
specific case
okay that's a very practical example
now i think the liberal solution to that
particular example will almost
always be something i disagree with but
it doesn't mean we can't have a solution
okay it just means that we want the
solution to be within a set of limiting
principles
conservatism is is really about the how
and i think that's incredibly important
it's it's why i'm a conservative
because the how is so important
especially when you're running for
office and your entire goal is to
developing a governing philosophy if
your entire
focus is on the what then that's just
being an activist
there's nothing wrong with that it's
also part of democracy demanding
something okay i want this to change but
that's activism
and it's not it's not the the judgment
required to actually solve the problem
without creating a lot of new problems
and it won't happen as so if the
conservatives solving it
it's not going to happen as fast it's
not going to happen maybe the way
it's not going to maybe maybe the maybe
the end result won't be as apparent
right because there's not like a program
that we want to create necessarily that
you can label
and you can say i put money into the
program for puppies
because we're trying to solve the puppy
problem and so i
i made the program it's puppies you know
and so and so to me liberals will do
that
and we'll be like uh yeah but it didn't
really solve the problem and in fact
we're just wasting a bunch of money on
it and it's like
puppies are still you know whatever
whatever the puppy problem is
and um you know so why don't we do this
let's tinker with the markets think you
know deregulate over here but it's not
as like
you can't wrap your arms around it as
well so liberals don't like that
but that's the conversation that has to
actually happen like let us
let us get let us be more open-minded
about what we need to do
but liberals need to be more open-minded
about the how
and how conservatives tend to solve
problems because it's more sustainable
and it takes into account more costs and
benefits and limiting principles i can't
stress enough how important limiting
principles are
i can describe what i mean by that in
more detail like
yeah no i i get it completely i mean i i
would call it conservation laws
you know a belief in a structure that
actually enforces some kind of
discipline over your
solution making and i do agree that it
is frequently absent
on the left um but in general i i have
the sense
that each perspective is
you know except for the entirely cynical
ones each perspective
has some sort of core insight that
drives it
and it's fused with a blind spot that
travels along with it
and so um
you're correct about the activist
demanding solutions to problems but
being
unaware of what functional solutions
look like
often functional solutions uh aren't
beautiful and they don't lend themselves
to some sound bite that's aspirational
and they function because of
conservation laws
so what i think has to happen
is that we need to each become aware
of the blind spots that are coupled with
what we see and so you know
we i think both recognize that liberals
are more likely to see
injustice um and there's a lot of it
and some of it is from some sort of
um identifiable source that can be
addressed with a solution and some of it
is just noise in the system that we're
probably stuck with but
the important thing is in the context of
solution making
to actually take advantage of things
that work so
let me give you an example on the left
people tend to be very upset at the
consequence of what they call capitalism
now
i don't know what they mean when they
say capitalism some of them mean
markets and this is an absurd position
because markets are one of the best
tools we have
but they're not a tool that can do
everything there's certain things
markets do beautifully and there's
certain things that they can't do at all
not even in principle and so what i want
to see in a future conversation
between those who might once have been
called liberals and those who might once
have been called conservatives
is a recognition that really the magic
would involve
wielding markets to greatest effect
by keeping them out of the stuff where
they do harm
by applying them to problems that they
are best positioned
to solve and by adding basically a
very um light system of incentives in
order to steer markets to solve the
problems we want solved rather than the
ones that they will end up solving if
left to their own
devices
and so you know what what do you do with
somebody who says you know capitalism is
the problem is
did i just defend capitalism or did i
attack it i'm not even sure
from a conservative point of view you've
defended it but
the you said but so like the health care
debate's a good
a good you know policy example of um
it can't be a total free market it's a
luxury good
and with uh you know defined there's
well just like anything there's scarcity
um
there's there's a lot of demand you know
it's complicated it's hard it's hard to
say that that could be a total free
market
conservatives would say it's never been
a free market um it's the most highly
regulated uh industry in america and
it's it's got all these
strange traditions built into it that
that have a history to them and a reason
for them but are very difficult to break
free from at this point
and we sort of piled a lot of weird
policies on top of it
and um but it doesn't mean you you
displace
all market incentives um you know so you
should use the market incentives
right and we have good examples of how
that might work i mean medicare
advantage
uses it's obviously a government program
but it uses the forces of the market to
make insurance companies compete against
one another
and therefore lower prices and premiums
for seniors and it came in way under
budget
so this is kind of the republican that
was a republican plan and i'm just
trying to like pat ourselves on the back
here but like
we're still allowing government to do it
because we understand that it's
you know it's it's not going to work as
a free market
we know that and so how do we expand on
that like so like that's sort of the
direction we want to go
with with healthcare and i you know if
it was up to me we would start solving
it with um
primary care i think that's like i don't
know this isn't like a whole long
discussion on healthcare policy but
direct primary care is a phenomenal um
gateway to i think solving so many
issues with health care
is that you know the best way the thing
that people need the most is
is a is a doctor they trust that they
choose
that they have a relationship with just
a primary care doctor
this is very important i think in health
care we have a system already in place
that's just sort of grown
slowly it's big here in houston i don't
know how big it is around the country
but a direct primary care system means
you know you're a doctor and you have a
subscription service
basically 75 bucks a month is about is
considered the average
so that's a cell phone bill it's a cheap
cell phone bill and now you have total
access to a doctor
as a primary care doctor it's not
insurance it's not catastrophic care
but it's total access to a primary care
doctor and that involves quite a bit of
services
that you're never paying for because you
just have a monthly bill
and people really like that it also
it also has the effect of reducing
premiums because because companies
will i'm really passionate about this
that's why i'm kind of going a lot of
details on this one
but uh so companies will actually uh
you know contract with a primary care
doctor in this in this particular model
and then everybody's premiums go down as
well so you have to have both
but you're reducing costs massively and
you're giving people what they want
again which is a relationship
and it's also an easy relationship it's
like okay i'm still sick i've got this
or i've got this like weird
mole on my nose something um
uh if i go see my doctor is there a
copay do i have to call my insurance
company like how do we set this up i
mean it's it's
people would get very annoyed with this
for good reasons
and this takes all of that out of it um
and it's it's i think it's it's it's a
great step forward so
but how do you but can everybody afford
75 bucks a month
well no not necessarily so so this is a
simple question
is that just subsidize it and give them
an hsa account a health savings account
is something everybody
americans should have and you can for
the people who can't afford it can you
subsidize that
that cost and so again government has a
role here
but it's a light touch and and you're
allowing market forces to compete
because doc yeah well a couple things
about the
health care system one it's a very
difficult problem to solve
in part because of a political feedback
loop in which
um very well-resourced industries have a
lot of influence over policy which
amounts to a veto
over whatever policy might best
serve the public and so
one of the problems if you try to apply
insurance
in a market context without proper
regulation what you get
is the inevitable discovery that the
profitable way
to make money in the context of
insurance is to ensure the people who
need it least
and abandon the people who need it most
and externalize the cost of their having
been
abandoned which we see again and again
so this is why
we don't have universal health care is
because it doesn't
serve the interests of those who are
making a profit
in health care at the insurance level
even though it would certainly
serve the nation and it's another place
where you know i'm
i'm not a socialist but there are places
where we need to socialize something
and it is you know a risk pool
that distributes bad luck um so that the
costs of it are evenly born
is desirable now not everything medical
is bad luck if you're smoking that's not
bad luck that may be the result of bad
decision making
but in general if you're struck by a
skin cancer because you
happen to get hit by a a bit of uv
radiation and it caused a mutation then
you know we all should pay some cost
in order to deal with the consequences
of that mutation rather than those
people who
have the bad luck uh can be medically
wiped out by it
and those people who have the good luck
uh effectively profit by uh having
rolled the dice and them
you know uh coming up uh positive
but in any case there is a readily
available
set of solutions they will be far from
perfect
but they could be vastly better than
what we have and i can't speak with any
authority to the situation you describe
um in the plan you just mentioned but
nonetheless it's a perfect
case for um a hybrid approach that
leverages
our ability to socialize costs that have
no
informational value right the same way
we do with
you know paramedic services or fire
suppression
um we should incentivize people to
behave in uh healthy ways to minimize
the overall cost of the system all of
these things are readily comprehensible
and could be built into a comprehensive
system were it not for the fact that
uh our collective interest is probably
um
for the foreseeable future in
competition with a private interest that
has more power
in government than than citizens do
yeah um okay so a lot to respond to
there that
that's part of it the healthcare
industry
and their lobbying industry they all
compete with one another
it's not like they're all united against
you know the interest of the people
they're they're united against each well
they're they're they're in combat
against each other
which it isn't all that unhealthy really
um because that you know the competing
interests kind of
keep one from becoming too powerful it's
it's extremely complicated the the the
key problem that you know
which is which which drives a lot of
people towards medicare for all is
you know the the pre-existing conditions
issue the catastrophic
injury issue you know the the brain
tumor
that costs ungodly amounts of money to
to deal with and you know one solution
is
okay so we could do socialized medicine
and just
pay for it out of federal tax dollars uh
the obamacare solution was basically
just require insurance companies to
to you know cover pre-existing
conditions
um the other solution is i i think
dividing healthcare up into about three
categories one is the direct primary
care that i
that i talked about earlier the second
is sort of your intermediate
um insurance you know a broken leg um
a temporary illness things like that and
then there's the catastrophic stuff you
know the pre-existing conditions the
lifelong issues that you're just gonna
have to deal with
um you know the catastrophic uh injury
um that's where the risk pool idea comes
in that's where we're going before
obamacare the state-run risk pools i
still think that's the better solution
or reinsurance programs a lot of states
that really
have driven down premiums while still
protecting people with pre-existing
conditions using reinsurance which
means once it gets to a certain once the
cost gets to a certain point that goes
to it you know
the bill goes to the government i that's
just a much more reasonable way and that
and that
what that does is it maintains the
market forces because i want
all of these health care entities to
continue to
to compete against each other right you
don't like big pharma
okay well then you should really like
insurance companies because they're the
ones who
negotiate with big pharma they're the
ones who keep those prices down
um you could have it be the government
but you'd still have the same
it wouldn't change anything people think
it changes something it doesn't
what what socialized medicine would do
is basically the way it even the way it
even comes into the budget that bernie
sanders proposes or that elizabeth
warren proposed which are basically all
around the same budgets and everybody
kind of agrees upon
the way you even get to that is by
maintaining current medicare and
reimbursement rates
which is by definition about 70 70 cents
on the dollar
so what you're really doing to maintain
that budget without you know is
you're still going to double people's
taxes but if you really want to pay
what the hospitals need to stay up to
their current level
you need to pay your body to triple
people's taxes
and so you're talking about price
controls fundamentally so that's a
that's a big consequence when you
implement price controls what happens
when you do that well you just produce
less
it's just as a simple rule of life if
you have price controls on something
that the person who produces that good
will produce less of it doctors have
less incentive to to get that next
specialty to become the best doctor
possible to do that next
you know breakthrough research because
they're not getting paid for it anymore
um i've talked i can talk to a million
places around here in houston
like more like independent service
industry you know people that
places that do dialysis you know and
that's their core
thing and then okay so if medicare if
you guys only get paid with medicare
reimbursement rates what happens oh we
just closed down we're done
that's it it's like not even it's not
even a complex
question for them it's just yeah we just
closed down so there's there's just less
there's just less of things and we start
to look a lot more like canada than uk
i think we have this sort of like
romantic view of what canada the uk look
like
um but we should we should talk to more
canadians and
britain's about that it's it's very it's
different
you know it's it's there's there's cost
to what they're doing
there's trade-offs and we can't pretend
there's no trade-offs
with this conversation i know this
wasn't meant to be like a super in-depth
healthcare issue thing but i i'm very
passionate about healthcare
in general and fixing it so i don't mind
talking about it but i know that wasn't
the point
no look i i like it for one thing um
you you are living up to my expectations
of you
um which is you know i've heard you
say this is about trade-offs i don't
know how much you know about
my scientific background but trade-offs
are where it's at with respect to
complex systems if you want to
understand them and
uh fix them if you're in the position to
manage them
then trade-offs are are the only game in
town
but i've heard you say that there are
aspects of this that should be
socialized there are aspects of this you
want to
use uh markets to address
you know i hear a perfectly reasonable
person recognizing that you have various
different levers and that they have
you know different costs and benefits
associated with them so
that's all music to my ears it does not
sound like the normal political
conversation i typically hear
where people have um effectively
religious devotion to some set of policy
proposals that they've been told
constitute the solution and therefore
anybody who stands in the way of them is
the enemy
you know i hear a practical person
saying look this is complex
it's never going to be perfect even the
systems that we think we would prefer
you should talk to people who actually
live under them which is very
interesting when you do
i never hear british people rave about
their system
but if you ask them what they prefer our
system i hear them say no
typically in fact i'm never i'm not sure
i've ever heard one say that they would
prefer to live
under our system so unless they have
unless they have a very bad cancer then
they're coming right here to houston
you know that's that's the only that's
the only difference um
we're the best at treating the most
cutting-edge diseases we have the best
of everything
um that's we pay a hell of a lot more
for it
and it's a too complex but we
that it's definitively true and this
gets lost in the conversation
like we have access to i think like
australia i could i could pull up so
many stats on this but they have like
access to like only 60
of the drugs that we do and that's the
cutting edge stuff right
obviously they have all the generics
they have all the old stuff but the new
stuff that's here now it's
it's expensive and people get really
upset about that it's not
it's not super obvious what you do about
that because you want it to be produced
in the first place
so i can put price controls on that
which is hr3 right that's been voted out
of the house twice now this past year
that's just it's just price controls
it's a very simple solution um
but it also means you'll never create
anymore you know
just which is like it's a bad thing too
no that's a problem you could solve with
subsidies and of course that becomes a
problem of its own if you become
addicted to the subsidy mechanism rather
than using it judiciously for things
where
it actually needs to be applied in order
to get uh
research funded but um so if we could
step back a second
uh yeah away from healthcare well yeah
healthcare can
can uh recede into the distance here but
i have the sense if you and i were to
meet at a barbecue
right didn't know each other just uh
happen to be standing in the same
corner of the lawn i have the sense that
we could go a long time
in discussion that we would disagree
about some things we'd agree about some
things
but i'm not sure i would necessarily
know where to place you politically
after that discussion i might just have
to ask you
that's because republicans are really
bad at communicating um
and so one of the reasons i ran was
because i i want to communicate our
ideas better
everything i've said is is very
republican um
and and not all of it you know so
there's some super conservatives who are
like wait a second did you say you
wanted to
you want to subsidize the dpc the direct
primary care into a health savings
account but like
well yeah but yeah i did you know and
they're like ah i can't say that
but but what we're really doing is is
actually combining it with medicaid so
there's
it's it's actually not this everything
i've said is not controversial on the
right
at all um there's going to be some
slight disagreements but
you know the problem with the
republicans with respect to health care
is that
we haven't really i know we're not
supposed to talk about health care
anymore it's just we haven't like come
together but in the broader sense
republicans are very bad at explaining
conservative ideology
we get way too wrapped up in you know
responding to the left
and this and it always makes us look bad
like i
for some reason and i do feel unfairly
treated just as a conservative
i think i think you know somebody who's
a centrist will
for some reason gives the left a lot
more leeway and criticizing the right
but as soon as we criticize the left it
feels like
it feels like all my centrists are like
why are you so divisive
i'm like i'm like i'm not i'm just i'm
just responding like come on
you know so that's the conservatives
feel that frustration it makes them very
angry
and then they don't communicate well and
like
you know proper communication and again
but proper key to make communication
based on a common set
of the logical rules of thought
um would go a really long way i
i think so that's that's my criticism of
the rights why it's why i got involved
in politics
well i mean i think there's something
else going on here
and i i frequently hear people on the
right
decrying the failures of the left as if
the left has never made any sense
and this i think is another tragedy
because the left has been
correct about a lot of stuff that's now
become part of
mainstream american values and so now i
hear people
on the right commonly espousing uh
positions that were once um
solidly on the left and have now just
been adopted as part of our
our core belief system and so i i think
i think you're you're both right
go ahead what what well i was gonna ask
what do you mean by that what
what are what are some values
let's say um tolerance
uh tolerance is something that was
fought for by the left
and i now find people on the right not
the far right
but the majority of the right is now
um entirely on board with
this idea it has become comfortable with
it and
you know that's um that's an achievement
right and so you know i'm not looking to
claim credit for my side where it hasn't
succeeded and indeed it's failed in many
places but
um but there is some sort of recognition
that we have the left and the right have
been navigating
together and they have achieved a great
deal
and then maybe progress has stalled um
and there's a question about where it's
stalled how how good are things
what still remains to be solved and what
would be what would we be foolish to
attempt to solve because we'll cause
greater problems than we have
and you know that's a conversation i
want to see i don't have the answers
myself but i do you know i probably
have talked to you before about the
hidden tribes report have you looked at
it
uh no i don't think we've talked about
that the hidden tribes report
is very interesting basically it
describes
a set of different ideological tribes
that are cryptically
within the american population and
the part of it that is so startling the
first time you read it
and then in my case certainly matches my
experience talking to people
is that almost 70 percent of the
american population
is in basic agreement about what america
should look like
and it's just not extreme in almost any
regard
right it has you know it's queasy
about abortion it doesn't want to see it
outlawed it doesn't want to see it
in the third trimester except in some
extreme circumstance but there's some
sort of
um well what the hidden tribes report
calls it is the exhausted middle
it's this large group of people who are
feeling unrepresented because what
happens is that our fringes
start bossing around the discussion and
they
put a giant divide between
factions and it keeps people who are on
the mainstream left and the mainstream
right from recognizing that actually
they you know in my experience i would
say
the mainstream left and the mainstream
right agree about what society
should look like they disagree about how
close we
are to that state and they disagree
about the ordering of priorities they
have the same values but they disagree
about which ones are the top values and
this is a place that actually i think
the right has been more correct one of
the things that i've
come to understand is that there's a
trade-off between values
but there's one value that doesn't fit
that rubric and it's liberty
and the reason liberty is special is
because liberty
realized liberty not abstract liberty
but real liberty that you can exercise
requires other problems to have been
solved right
so if you're medically compromised then
you're not really free so to liberate
you we have to solve
your you know your medical jeopardy
problem for example
if you want to be really free we have to
figure out a way to
get you a proper education because
education provides the tools that will
allow you to use that liberty
for something worthwhile so liberty is
the integrative
value at the point you've achieved all
of the stuff necessary to get liberty
you don't have much left to do
and so um now that said i think the
right has been a little bit
um deaf to the distinction between
abstract liberty you know in theory
you're free
but in a practical sense you're not
because you're
you can't earn a wage for example um
but that were we to recognize
that we could use liberty as a proxy for
the overall success
of our system and that our obligation
was to try to get liberty to as many
americans as we can which is to say
to free them from the things that block
um the exercise of liberty then
that's a pretty good way of dealing with
the trade-offs because as you go too far
in the direction of one value and it
begins to erode another it shows up
as a deficit of liberty and so in any
case it's a way it's a way to
recognize that although we sound like we
disagree
very frequently we're not disagreeing
over
something substantial that we you know
i i almost never meet an american that
likes the idea
that your skin color should be an
important
uh indicator of your likelihood of
success
right whether you're on the right or the
left you want to see a nation in which
skin color just
doesn't have an implication for success
right that's what all the decent people
want
um and so anyway that's great that we've
achieved that it wasn't always that way
so i i hope that those on the left and
those on the right who are not part of
these
fringes that have a uh a toxic view of
how we should behave towards each other
can actually recognize how much we would
have to gain if we could have the
conversation about
where where we disagree for example
about how to prioritize our liberties
or our values but yeah
the distinction on how we view liberty
is an important one i've
actually broke i agree with it and i
wrote about it in the op-ed i did on
on the reason the reason that we're so
divided politically
on whether lockdowns are good or bad
and the notion that different that
there's a different description of
liberty on the right and the left and
that's and that is that's one of the
reasons we differ politically
so i agree with it and i certainly fall
into the category of of
believing that more liberty is good and
if we're going to take away some kind of
liberty
for the sake of a service we better have
a very very good reason
uh for doing so and and we can it's not
to say we can't have both but we need to
be very careful about what that
looks like of course you know and
providing
government-provided institutions like
you know education
um makes a lot of sense if you want
people to pursue their happiness which
is the ultimate
goal of government to protect the right
to pursue your happiness
and your life and your liberty these are
inaudible rights that it's government's
job to protect
and and that and that involves setting
up a set of structures so that you're
able to pursue
those things and if those structures are
failing then that's something we should
know
um so yeah i think we we could we could
agree on that we probably still fall a
little bit different
on the spectrum about how far to go um
but you know uh the other thing you were
saying about um
the the uh the exhausted middle that's
an interesting part
and you know this gets into some
political science insights i think and
you know how the heck do you establish a
sort of moderate platform like what does
that look like
and you know i i don't know i'm not
there yet i can't figure it out
necessarily because
what i've noticed is that the it's very
difficult
for politicians on the right or the left
to even like
figure out what the middle is because
people have different opinions in the
middle and it can mean a few things
sometimes you just have different
opinions sometimes you create the lesson
times you agree with the right you know
maybe you're really politically attuned
but but you just have different and so
you consider yourself an independent uh
but sometimes it just means
i just take my kids to school i'm trying
to just work and
i'm just independent because everybody
seems crazy right and so they're just
they're not just they're just not
involved in politics so you really don't
even you're not really sure how to reach
that voter they might have just seen you
on tv once and they kind of like you
they like the way you talk and okay
that's it
so it's um it's very difficult to
capture that movement
is is my point and it's very difficult
to establish
a a platform around it and and i think
that's the
that's that's the challenge that we'll
continue to see but it is frustrating
because like you used abortion as an
example
um yeah i mean public opinion would show
exactly what you just said but 12 weeks
if we went by pure 12 like a public
opinion on abortion the limit would be
12 weeks
um i'll tell you what if that was
that was proposed right now all
conservatives would vote for it we think
it's an amazing victory
and it would calm the conversation down
quite a bit
quite a bit um we are extreme in this
country
on abortion compared to france and all
european countries basically
they all have 12 weeks as the limit
um you know it's an interesting example
that goes to show like
how strange this
system is um it's because people play in
teams
you know people have a need to play in
teams and it's also i've noticed that
voters it's about trust
and so they you know maybe a lot of you
know independent liberals and
independent conservatives
i might disagree with me or tulsi on
on something um but they just there's
it's more of a predisposition you know
conservatism is a disposition
liberalism is kind of a disposition and
you know you're just predisposed to
trust whoever
espouses you know the most amount of
your ideas and it's really difficult to
find that
that middle because it's a knife edge
and it falls away rather quickly
um that's the challenge i don't have the
solution necessarily it's just it's
interesting to talk about well i got two
last points for you i know you have to
go and i want to be respectful of your
time
but one thing that we discovered i was
surprised at it
was that the unity 2020
um platform that's not even the right
word for it but the structure that
brought people
to us did something unexpected
which is not only did it bring people
equally from the right and the left
but it brought in something like 25
percent
of our volunteers are people who were
not going to vote
so this uh disengaged group who i think
you know the disengage group involves
two subgroups one of them
is apathetic and the other one is so
frustrated that they've walked away
and the difficulty that you talk about
of finding something that actually
appeals to that exhausted middle
is something i think we've tapped into
and so maybe that's a model of something
but the other thing i wanted to say is i
i have now run into this as somebody who
doesn't think of myself as a centrist
i began when i introduced the plan
i described it as taking somebody from
the center left and the center right and
i realized
quickly thereafter what a mistake it was
to use the term center
because center means two different
things and one of them is not very
useful
the center has a kind of a tepid
feel to it right that it's not very
ambitious or interesting
it's just it's almost a kind of
resignation
the other thing that the center is the
reason i invoked it
is that i know that even those of us who
aren't anywhere near the center
politically
have to meet there in order to discuss
what's actually in the interest
of the nation at the center is the
natural meeting place
even for those who don't see themselves
as as centrists and so
what i really want is a view of center
in which we don't assume
a mild version of policy but we take
kind of an a la carte version where
there are things that the right has
correct and where the right is correct
we ought to go with it
and there are other places where the
left has it correct and we ought to
go with those things but we ought to do
it in discussion with each other
so that we don't keep suffering from the
pendulum swinging or the excesses of one
side
versus the other but what we really find
is
what is possible and how we can get
there
at the lowest possible price
and you know isn't that inherently the
patriotic conversation
yeah i mean you know an easy way to
solve that
you know is maybe a an agreement in
congress to
have more discreet voting what i mean by
that is
the coronavirus packages are a perfect
example of this where
you know we don't have to wait multiple
weeks
to spend trillions of dollars that's
kind of an absurd
thing it's like oh no because we got to
negotiate they want this so we want this
but it's like by the way the thing we
want you also want it's bipartisan
legislation like let me give you an
example
the restart act it's basically more
targeted ppp funding
we would spend money on that tomorrow
and it's
all and democrats would vote for it
republicans would vote for it
um i need nancy pelosi to bring that to
the floor
i called for it did it on twitter today
i gave everybody her number
so they could call and ask her and uh
just i'm sure she does not like me
but uh but uh i was like why don't we
just vote okay you want to vote for post
office stuff on saturday
we can vote on this too it's bipartisan
america needs it
like just just vote on that oh because
it doesn't give you leverage for the
for the other stuff you want and that's
why that's gross that's not patriotic
it's like we agree on it and just you
can argue with this about all bills and
i'm sure republicans have done the same
thing i just wasn't in congress
you know so um
and they did but honestly i don't think
it was to the same extent like
if you get there all of these
major bills that get pushed through
they're very easy for me to argue
against
and you don't have to make them that
easy for me to argue against you know
this is what i do i create these here's
the truth videos i say like why i'm not
voting for this why it's bad idea
why it's bad policy don't vote for this
even though it has a nice sounding name
right like
they always have a nice sounding name
but um
they the democrats could make it very
hard for me to vote against that they
could they could strip
out some like like 10 of what's in that
they could strip out the poison pills
and we could just vote on stuff we agree
on the senate would vote on it it would
go to the president's desk he would sign
it
you could do that it's not it's it's
very easy
it's just a decision that has to happen
you know and it's like
you know that simple thing you don't
need to change the superstructure of
who's going to run for president right
it's just like a
just vote for discrete solutions for
discrete problems
you know and and some people call for
this often right like the the one
issue voting i don't know if that's the
right answer either because
like that would take just a lot of time
and sometimes it's okay to just have a
bipartisan negotiation and sometimes it
works
sometimes um it's happened a few times
throughout this session
like on big stuff it happens every day
on little stuff that nobody knows about
um
but uh on the big stuff like informing
retirement savings for instance like
that was a big one the first step act
like that's a
that's a decent one i mean you could
argue the cares act is you know it
happened that way
but the police reform bill that easily
that was not very far apart
it easily could have just because we're
always like hey fine you want to
do all that fine but please just do a
little bit less but you know i
we're agreeing that on the action but
like
just just don't spend three times as
much money please like it's it's not
necessary
you know it and if we agree on
everything at that
80 percent level i it's hard to argue
against why why would one just pass that
and especially with something like the
restart act again
small business funding right now is is
extremely important so
you know you don't even need two
candidates in the presidency to
you know differing sides for this it's
just a that's a simple solution
well i hate to say it and i hate to say
it to you of all people
but this really is the point is that the
system
the mystery you point to about why we
just don't simply do the stuff that's
obviously at the public's interest and
that would be popular
is because the system is built to serve
a different interest that its real
constituents aren't the public and so
the public is i mean this has now been
established through research that
um the public's desire for policy has
almost no influence
over what legislation we pass that you
know the public
is uh playing a role in that game
because it's votes
a portion power between the parties but
the public's well-being is not the
purpose of policy at this point and you
know
that's deeply unpatriotic it's a
solvable
problem but it can't be solved if we
subscribe to the rules we've been told
we have to stick to
which is exactly why unity 2020 exists
and why something
like it must exist yeah and one of the
reasons that's
that's true also is now having been in
politics for
a pretty short amount of time and kind
of seeing
what incentives do we respond to as a
politician
um it's really simple it's it's your
votes like you you need
you need your constituents to devote you
back in so you have to do something you
have to do things that they like
at least 51 of the time um
that's always fundamentally true i know
a lot of people
put a lot more weight on like the
lobbyist interests and all that
in my very limited experience that has
that has a lot less weight
um you know the the lobbyists in
washington provide a lot of
they're like a they're they provide
details that you would never know about
for a given industry and you know it
doesn't mean there's some
conniving ill intention there it's just
you know we it's good that we know these
things because
these industries tend to employ hundreds
of thousands of people so that's
it's okay for us to know that um i
i've never i don't see them holding a
lot of sway uh because they also compete
with one another too so it's
you know and your job as a politician
with good judgments to be like are you
bsing me or you because you know it's
like
that's your job figure it out and um and
figure out like what's it's actually
going to do for for my constituents and
so
i i guess you might fear that some group
hates you so much
that they might spend a lot of money in
your district but that's also very rare
um that more happens when that does
happen from say a super pac it's always
it's funded by one person it's like you
know it's it's billionaires on one side
versus billionaires on another side and
that's
i don't really have a problem with that
it's it's competing um i don't know how
to stop that without truly infringing on
people's rights to
to free speech maybe there should be
more transparency behind it i think we
would all agree on that um
but but there is in fact people don't
realize how much
there actually is with super pacs the
donors are known
so you know i guess what i'm getting at
is so okay so why won't pelosi
put that stuff on the floor and
because i guess maybe because
everybody's first election is a primary
election
you know maybe that's it um
maybe because the loudest voices tend to
tend to have the most influence and
the um the there's a graph um
one of my political science teachers
drew for us
and uh it was very insightful and it was
the um uh it was the
the word so think of it this way it's
it's hard to visualize but
try it's think of like a smiley face
graph so that kind of bell curve
all right and what is what does that uh
represent and
and so on the x-axis you're
you know the left and the right okay
and i almost need to draw it to
to like describe it correctly but it's
um
it's you know it's it's trying to
describe
a simple fact which is that the people
in the middle
by nature of being in the middle are not
very passionate
about a given policy you know they're
more likely to say i mean that kind of
makes sense and i mean that kind of
makes sense
i don't know um people on the fringes
are far more likely to to be extremely
loud about a policy be highly passionate
and this is the voices that get heard in
politics and this is what politicians
have to respond to because these people
these people influence that whether we
like it or not
those people in the fringes influence
the people in the middle
because the people in the middle have
again they have a disposition even if
you're an independent
everybody has a disposition on a
spectrum of left to right
and i think that's psychologically true
we're wired a certain way
and so you trust even though you're not
you're not like i don't like the way
those radical conservatives are talking
but i still trust them more
um to kind of kind of know the direction
that i kind of want to go
and so i'm with that and they're really
mad and they're really passionate and so
they've got to know what they're talking
about
so this gets to another cultural problem
we have where i think we've associated
passion with sophistication
a little bit too much like oh wow
they're so angry they must have a good
point
do they though you know like that's a
that's that's i'm not so sure
um you know somebody's people just rile
themselves up or it's just
faking it um but i think it's mostly
telling yourself a narrative of anger
over and over again and then you sort of
you actually tend to believe it but
that's what happens
and so that's what politicians end up
responding to and that's why
again we only fear our voters that's all
that's all we actually fear
um and i don't i don't think i don't
know of anybody who's any different
you know i i haven't i haven't seen this
sort of corrupt behavior that i think
people envision a lot i'm not saying it
doesn't exist
i haven't been up there a long long long
time
but it's um it's not quite what people
think
i don't think more complicated it
doesn't look the way we expect
it to look you know this it's a banality
of evil phenomenon where
it doesn't look very dramatic at all
right the consequences of it are ghastly
in my opinion but
the actual way that it functions looks
like business
and you know why won't pelosi bring
obviously good legislation um
the answer is because obviously good
legislation
is not in her interest and it's not in
the
interests of the dnc and it's not in the
interests
of the real constituents of the party
and we can only read that
indirectly by the failure decade after
decade
to do the obvious right
yeah so so on that particular question i
actually because i have an answer so
this is how i see this play out
i'm just on this on this specific bill
that we're talking about
so it's pretty obvious that pelosi won't
bring that to the floor because then
trump will sign it and he'll
he'll run a victory lap and that'll make
her very mad and it'll look good he
might get reelected
so that's that's exactly why it doesn't
get put to the floor
now now but the question is is like why
if it's good for everybody why don't
they hold her accountable
that's the question and so and so and
here's the answer and i see it play out
like on twitter okay i see it play out
on the commentary which is pelosi's
defending us and i'll see people say
this
she's defending us by by waiting for a
better deal she's looking out for us
like people believe this
so she's responding to her constituents
in a sense
because they trust her now i disagree
with that logic
clearly but i but i at least can observe
what's what i see to be happening here
well uh i'm more cynical than you are
about
this question maybe because i'm older
but
um i watched the democratic party
sabotage bernie sanders in 2016
because it preferred trump and the whole
time
it also decried the possibility of the
election of trump and then the fact of
the election
of trump as you know the beginning of
the end of civilization
and none of it made any sense this is
really about
the fact that um bernie sanders
for better or worse was a challenge to
standard operating procedure in the
democratic party he was not supposed to
become
a viable candidate in the primary and
the thing that that does not get said
is that donald trump was as they viewed
it
less of a threat to the things that were
important to the functioning of the
party than bernie sanders was
because although i find bernie sanders
view
of what policies we should enact to be
backward looking he did in fact want to
change
things in a way that a
status quo based dnc just couldn't
tolerate
yeah but i always give bernie that he's
genuine oh yeah i mean
absolutely he's a real patriot yeah
yeah but i disagree with him on
literally everything oh that's funny
but but he's but he's genuine he he
believes what he believes that is that
has always been true about bernie
sanders um he has flip-flopped on some
things
which um he used to be a true socialist
um
which means you have to be a nationalist
this is important because
like you kind of have to be if you the
open border policy of the new democratic
left
is is not what bernie sanders was in
favor of in 2015. he said so he was very
clear about this um again because if
you're going to have a welfare state
then you also have to have borders in a
very strict immigration system
so you can't have both um
it's impossible because there's no
arguing with that
sweden can do it um they're they're
having trouble because they've gotten a
lot of immigration
but they have a super tight-knit social
fabric it's
just a very different can't even compare
ourselves to sweden they're 99
white people i it's just not the same um
but
anyway i agree with you he's always been
consistent
i i don't know how to establish the
motives of
of the dnc it's very it's interesting
it's like we kind of just sit back as
conservatives and just kind of sort of
like like laugh at it um when we see
what goes on and like you know i mean
the convention has been interesting just
like because there's very different
things happening
at different times in the convention
you've got people advocating for the
downfall of capitalism
one minute um you know you've got the
you know you've got it's telling people
to they can kneel for the anthem one
minute but then they play like a super
patriotic
rendition of the anthem and other men
it's very contradictory
um and also i i i feel to me it's it's
gaslighting it's like look look this is
what we are it's kind of like um
kind of like their dating profile
benjamin bureau used this like it's like
it's like this is the this is the bumble
dating profile but this is like who we
really are
um and so it seems to me a little bit of
that um
but you know it's it's i'm sure that
people will i'm sure our convention will
be uh
equally uh susceptible to lots of
interesting criticisms as well i don't
even know what it's going to look like
but you know we'll see um
yeah i don't know what i was even
responding to now i've just been
rambling on
well i was i was alleging the deep
corruption of the dnc and i must say
it's not like i think the rnc
is less corrupt in fact i could make an
argument that the dnc
learned its game from the rnc but the
rnc is
less worthy of that discussion at the
moment because
trump actually beat it right
sanders stood a chance of beating the
dnc but he failed to
but donald trump actually did so in some
sense you know at least something new
and different has happened in the
republican party
um that has changed the dynamic um
i i you know i'm afraid of
uh donald trump's leadership
style and the hazard that it creates for
the nation and the world
but he did demonstrate that it was
possible um to
to gain the presidency in spite of
opposition
from the highest echelons of the party
so
um that was an important lesson and you
know it's one that
uh i think we should learn from anyway i
can tell that you have to go because
even though you're still here discussing
these things people are passing through
your office i think they're trying to
send you a message
i think so too i don't even know what
time it is yeah oh yeah we went way past
so um that's all right it was a fun
discussion
and um you know uh happy to be
you know in front of your audience so
now thank you brett so it's always fun
i always gotta like i just gotta get my
thinking cap on when i'm when i'm uh
discussing things with you i was like i
was i thought at first it was just going
to be you and eric and i was like
he's two brainiacs
too much well i i really enjoy the
conversations with you too dan
um they are heartening and they restore
my faith that there are there are good
people in government
attempting to do the public's bidding
and uh i wish you luck
yeah it'd be great to have uh tulsi with
us next time she's a she's a good friend
she's fun to hang out with uh yeah she's
she's a good one for sure
i really like tulsi yes uh i'm very fond
of tulsi also and i was really
disappointed that we couldn't
uh pull this off with her today i really
hope that um when she's done with
her obligations that she'll come back on
with us and
eric that'd be great
well thanks for having me on brett all
right thanks dan
um and uh let me just tell my audience
that there is a link that they can go to
if they wish to discuss
this this interaction that we've had
with the democracy ai tool what is the
link for that zach
ah it's democracy.articles
democracy.articlesofunity.org and you
can see it at the bottom of your screen
thanks again dan crenshaw and uh thanks
everybody for tuning in to our campfire
unity 2020 marches on
be well everyone
b
you